we want to start out this news program
with giving our love and hearts
to india we've all been reading about
the covid crisis there
and they've been hit with 300 000 new
cases a day
more than any country at its peak
entertainment tonight reports that
priyanka chopra jonas and nick jonas
have teamed up with give india for an
urgent fundraiser and they announced the
news
on instagram please take a look at this
even as the medics learn more about the
virus
the threat continues to loom over the
past few weeks
millions of indians unleashed the power
of social media to do good
and that is so inspiring i'm taking your
lead and carrying it forward
we're appealing to you all to contribute
towards the healthcare system which is
at a breaking point right now so you can
go to priyanka's instagram
and her instagram directs you to give
india.org
you don't have to donate a ton of money
like every single dollar
helps they need the help right now so uh
we're sending all of our love
out to uh everyone in india and our show
actually airs in india on z
cafe so we're just wanting you to know
how much we're with you
i actually love india so much it's a
country
that i've traveled through very
thoughtfully throughout my
adult life and my grandfather was
actually born in agra
my grandfather yeah maurice barrymore i
didn't know that yes
i feel such a deep connection and i want
to thank
uh the jonases for giving us a direct
and easy way to contribute yeah and
that's the word connection we are all
connected connected this has been a
global thing we've been going through it
i don't know if you know this but may is
mental health awareness month and we've
got some huge news
about expanding mental health care as
well npr reports cvs they've started a
pilot program
to bring counseling right into their
stores
and this is a game changer for making
mental health more accessible
they're gonna have counselors in dozens
of stores and they hope to hit 34 stores
this year and they're targeting
specifically diverse areas that are
traditionally cut off
from health mental health options and
they're working to cut the out-of-pocket
costs for people and it's so important
to be having this conversation about
mental health because sometimes there's
a stigma attached to it
you know and i think now more than ever
coming out of this
um we need to be there for each other
the fact that
cvs is going to open their doors
potentially work with insurers
and have this convenient place
to possibly go is such a game changer my
hearts
and hats is off to cvs may other
businesses follow in your footsteps yes
a major shout out
to them and let's have this conversation
absolutely
[Music]
you